social work is not for you
before I explain why
my name is Aaliyah Nurideen
I am a licensed clinical social worker
a mental health therapist
and a social and cultural analyst
let me break down why social work may not be for you
so if you are in the field because you feel like you want to save everybody
this is not the field for you
social work is more than just being a saviour
and that in turn
will reflect in the way that you treat clients
it will reflect in the way that you operate within systems
and it will reflect in the way that you view
the clients that you're working with
everyone does not need saving
everyone has built in strengths and supports
and those need to be advocated more for and empowered
and by assuming that this population or this client
or this person or this system needs to be saved by you
you are in fact
perpetuating a power dynamic in which you hold the keys and you hold the power
and this client or this client system needs to be grateful to you
social work is not for you if you're uncomfortable addressing white privilege
oppression and racism
if you cannot hold space to acknowledge these systems and historical oppression
you cannot be a social worker
and to be clear
holding space means not being defensive
holding space means sitting with and acknowledging how white privilege
power oppression
and racism is built within the systems that we work in
social work is not for you if you do not believe in social justice
and dignity and worth of a person
social work has a specific code of ethics that professionals
must not only abide by
but find value in
dignity and worth of a person
and social justice *are* among some of the core values of social workers
if you do not align with an advocacy within the field
social work is not for you
there are many paths to be a psychotherapist
if that is what you want to do in your career
there are many paths that do not have an aligned set of values
and codes of ethics for the profession
if you do not abide by these
to your core social working for you